[Music]
could this be hollywood's new power
couple i mean
yeah et's learned leonardo dicaprio and
gigi hadid are spending time together
after his split from longtime girlfriend
camila marone all the girls out there
like we wanted to be your date leo
a source tells e.t leo likes gigi but
things are still new so yeah we might
not see these two arm in arm on the red
carpet any time soon which wouldn't be a
total shocker leo and camila never made
any true public appearances together
despite dating for nearly five years the
most they ever did was sit together at
the oscars
but they walked that carpet separately a
noted change from leo's previous
romances with the likes of giselle
bunchen and bar rafaeli which were well
documented by photogs on and off the red
carpet all i have to say there's a lot
harder jobs in the world than doing than
doing what i do and and and for the
price that i have to pay is to lose some
autonomy autonomy that's
that's just the way it goes i i'd quit
if it was that big of a deal since this
latest breakup we hear the actors turn
to his inner circle for support what
keeps me grounded is my friends and
family our source notes leo's been
hanging out with his guy friends since
his split i have a good
a solid group of you know friends that
i've known
for a long time that you know i i trust
with my life you know
and that's good
as for gigi it's been about a year since
she and zayn malik called it quits they
share a daughter two-year-old kai i
think she's a genius but i think that's
what everyone says
about their kids gigi and zayn's breakup
came amid controversy
the model's mother yolanda hadid accused
the former one direction member of
physical assault
at the time et learned yolanda and zane
were upset the allegation went public
and gigi and her mom never had an issue
over the incident a source adding quote
zayn will be in the family's lives
forever and everyone hopes one day they
can all move on fast forward to today
and gigi's sharing her newfound
perspective on life in the spotlight how
do you deal gigi with the celebrity side
of your job i think that you know for
everyone there's a time where it can be
overwhelming and
all you can
all you are is human i mean i've learned
the hard way and that just means that i
wasn't always perfect and i made
mistakes one time serena williams told
me nothing's in the press more than
three weeks
breathe learn from it get through it you
learn from things like that and we'll
just need to learn to wait for more
details about her rumored new romance
[Music]
you